yeah
[Applause]
in 2017 populism was in full flow around
the world but the election of french
president emmanuel macro seemed to
signal its resounding defeat at least in
france
but five years on as the country heads
to the polls once again the french are
fed up
normally this despondency spells defeat
for sitting presidents but macron is
leading in all the polls
so why are the french so miserable
[Music]
it's market day in horsair a town about
200 kilometers southeast of paris
ocer is a typical provincial city in
france but is also a bellwether
it's back the winner in every french
presidential race for 40 years
and in 2022 there's only one victor in
sight
in 2017 emmanuel macron swept to power
with a party that was little more than a
year old
at 39 he was the youngest president in
french history
he promised to unite the country and
propose sweeping reforms
his term in office has been turbulent
rocked by national and international
events
but on macron's watch france has also
become more entrepreneurial and business
friendly
incomes have risen and unemployment has
dropped
faced with a pandemic his stimulus
package helped deliver the strongest
economic growth since the late 1960s
ensuring a quick recovery to
pre-pandemic levels
[Music]
no surprise then that macron's been odds
on to return to power since the
economist began to forecast this year's
election you can see our latest
prediction by clicking on the link
below the market shoppers don't exactly
seem overjoyed at the
[Music]
gaelic grumpiness may not seem a
surprise
some argue pessimism is part of the
french psyche
there's even a french word for it
[Music]
with the war in ukraine the cost of
living post-pandemic and rising fuel
prices perhaps there is reason for much
of the rich world to feel gloomy right
now
but for the french this discontent runs
deeper
a recent survey found that
three-quarters of them thought france
was in decline
[Music]
for market traders like farmer denis
chatelain business is good
but he's still fed up and it's the
president who bears the brunt of his
anger
his firm on the outskirts of assa is
only a two-hour drive from paris but to
denny it's a world away from the seat of
the french presidency
as he sees it macron's policies have
really been about looking after business
leaders and shareholders
[Music]
it's not unusual for the french to blame
their woes on whoever is president
it comes with the territory for leaders
who get to exercise the huge power that
is bestowed on that office
but the mood in ocean points to a sense
of disconnection that is not just
political
but sarah is in the sparsely populated
band of france known as the diagonal
duvet or empty diagonal
like many mid-sized french towns it
suffers from industrial decline and with
no fast train to paris its population is
effectively cut off from the job
opportunities in france's big urban
centres
it was in places like ausai where people
rely on their cars that the zhilejon or
yellow vest movement sprung from in 2018
[Applause]
originally a protest against the tax
rise on petrol and diesel that
transformed into a wider anti-government
rebellion today the movement has
somewhat dissipated but many former
members are still taking to the street
to air other grievances
it's this group's 35th weekly protest in
a row
this time against france's coveted
restrictions
[Music]
in an effort to get more people
vaccinated macron banned many employees
in customer facing roles from working
unless they were jabbed a policy which
angered many
as with immigration and taxation it's
another issue that has been taken up
with relish by france's populist
politicians deepening the divide in
french society
more than 50 of voters say they'd vote
for a populist candidate in the first
round of the election
such is the support for populist parties
that two different hard-right candidates
have helped define this year's election
marine le pen who faced macron in the
second round in 2017 and newcomer eric
zamor a former journalist who was
recently convicted for inciting racial
hatred
emmanuel bertrand is the moore's local
coordinator in the region
today he and his team are door knocking
in chablis a town 20 kilometers outside
of our sure
zamor set up the reconquest party just a
few months ago with a promise to slash
immigration and taxes
it's a blend that initially proved
potent on the doorstep tapping into a
nostalgic idea of france
even if it's now started to go a little
flat
zamor and to a greater extent le pen's
popularity points to the depth of the
geographical divide in france already
apparent five years ago in the second
round of the 2017 election ocean voted
for macron but the further away from the
city you go the higher the vote for le
pen
this same dynamic can be seen around
urban centres throughout the country
[Music]
in 2022 osei offers another less
scientific way of reading the state of
the nation
and in the past few years he's noticed a
town that's becoming increasingly
disillusioned
macron came to power at the head of a
centrist movement that took widespread
support from the republicans and the
socialists the established parties of
the mainstream right and left
neither has fully recovered
in a recent survey 30 of those who are
considering voting for macron say it's
by default rather than choice as no
other candidate convinces them
under the cover of darkness barcelona's
elusive macron supporters are
outpostering
if he does win again it would be a
symbolic moment the first french
president for 20 years to win a second
term
[Music]
and it would put him in good stead to
introduce new reforms
but with a fed up population unimpressed
by its president there may be questions
over the strength of his mandate
this could spell trouble when the
political mood of the french public
turns even gloomier
for macron however hard-fought this
election becomes
winning it may prove to be the easy part
[Music]
if you'd like to see more about our
forecast for the 2022 french election
click the link
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe